Here's an example of OCL. In this case,
we're talking about using the OCL as an extension to a class model diagram.
In the class model diagram, there's an account class. The account class has
a deposit operation. That operation takes in a real number called amount.
The pre keyword indicates the precondition, in this case,
that the amount being provided in this deposit is greater than zero.
The postcondition, indicated by the post keyword is indicating what must be
true after the execution of this particular operation.
In particular, the balance afterwards must be equal to
the balance before plus the amount that was deposited.